por el dx empezamos con tres a la menos
cuatro que es lo mismo que uno sobre 3 a
la 4 desde las 3 27 y luego 81 es 1
sobre 81 tenemos 3 a la menos 3 y ahora
voy a usar un color que se vea mejor
tenemos 3 a la menos 3 que es igual a 1
sobre 3 a la 3 que es igual a 1 sobre 27
así que pasamos de un muy pequeño valor
a uno pequeño pero no tanto el siguiente
será 3 a la menos 2 que es igual a 1
sobre 9 el siguiente será 3 a la 03 a la
0 que simplemente es igual a 1
hemos venido obteniendo valores más
grandes y más grandes pero estamos cerca
de explotar tenemos 3 a la 1 que es
igual a 3 3 a la 2 y la 3 a la 2 que es
igual a 9 3 a la 3 327 3 a la 4 que es
81 3 a las 5 es
43 ahora hagamos una gráfica de esto
donde podamos observar qué tan rápido
estamos explotando
voy a dibujar mi eje bien aquí tengo mi
eje x y este de acá es mi eje y bien ese
es el eje y ahora vamos a hacer los
incrementos que sean en 5 lo que quiero
dibujar es la forma general de la
gráfica este mejor vuelvo a hacer un eje
voy a repetir el eje aquí está 5 10 15 y
chispas así no va a llegar 81
creo que tendré que hacer otra vez todo
bueno lo voy a pintar aquí abajo como
puedes observar todos los valores serán
positivos puesto que mi base es positiva
bueno aquí estará el eje como esto bien
con eso es suficiente y ahora tendré 10
20 30 40 50 60 70 80 aquí está el 80
aquí está el 10 y aquí el 30 y sólo los
quiero como una aproximación
y aquí estará 5 negativo
y aquí 5 positivo pero creo que cambiaré
la escala y mejor aquí estará el menos
uno el menos 2 - 3 - 4 y de este lado 1
2 3 y 4 así que cuando x vale 0 llévale
uno sí que vale 1 lo que está más o
menos por aquí y cuando x vale uno que
vale tres que es más o menos por aquí
cuando x vale 269 que está ahora aquí
para x igual a 3 627 que está
aquí cuando x es igual a 4 y ese fue
hasta 81 si en 81 rápidamente esto está
creciendo y para 5 sería 243 que ya ni
cabe en mi pantalla y cuando x es
negativo el resultado es pequeño y cada
vez más pequeño acercándose a cero a
medida que x toma valores negativos más
pequeños pero digamos 3 a la menos 1000
3 a la menos un millón obtendremos cada
vez números más cercanos a cero sin
nunca llegar a cero
venimos desde menos infinito en equis
alejándonos poco a poco de cero y al
pasar a los positivos va am explota y
continúa explotando siempre creciendo y
así continuará creciendo siempre bueno
la idea es mostrarte que las funciones
exponenciales son muy dramáticas el
siempre podremos construir una que
crezca a una tasa mayor por ejemplo si
hiciéramos de igual a equis a la equis
ésta se expande más rápido pero de las
que trabajamos en la vida diaria ésta es
un buen ejemplo ahora pasemos a hacer
algunos problemas que nos permitan
apreciar mejor las funciones
exponenciales por ejemplo qué tal si
alguien inicia una cadena de mensajes
enviando una carta de manera que en la
semana 1 envía la carta a 10 personas y
el mensaje en la carta dice tienes que
enviar esta carta a otras 10 personas
porque si no lo haces
tendrás mala suerte
caerá el cabello o te casarás con una
rana oa cosas de ese estilo
las 10 personas aceptan entonces ellos
le envían la carta cada uno a 10
personas en la siguiente semana en la
semana 2 tenemos que cada una de las
diez personas originales envía 10 cartas
cada uno y ahora tenemos a 100 personas
esto es 10 veces 10 100 cartas se
enviaron veamos
se enviaron aquí 10 cartas aquí 100 y en
la semana 3 que es lo que va a pasar
cada una de estas 100 personas enviará a
10 nuevas bueno tomando en cuenta que
todos participan en la cadena ahora son
1000 los que recibieron la carta y cuál
es el patrón general de lo que estamos
viendo aquí es decir en la semana en la
semana n n es el número de la semana que
estamos hablando tendríamos diez a la n
si 10 a la n personas que reciben que
reciben
a la carta
si te preguntarás cuántas personas
recibirán la carta en la sexta semana
cuántas personas lo recibirán en la
sexta semana bueno es diez a la sexta
potencia diez a las seis es uno con seis
ceros y es un millón un millón de
personas recibirán la carta sólo en seis
semanas por el hecho de haber enviado
cada uno 10 por semana obviamente en el
mundo real la mayoría de las personas
tira estas cartas a la basura y no
logras tener un impacto como el del
ejemplo pero si tu cadena de mensajes
fuera exitosa a las seis semanas tendrás
un millón de gentes y a las nueve
semanas tendrás mil millones de personas
eventualmente ya no habrá personas en el
mundo que puedan recibir la carta